Those.
Oh those.
Jobs.
Those sorry you are. Right.
Like money on their minds.
Joshua martin and i first came to nimbin
when i was about two years old i came
out with my parents from england
and we were often western australia and
travelled right the way across the country.
My parents were basically searching for
an alternative lifestyle to what they'd
experienced when they were my age
in wind and they ended up in nimbin
and they were sort of directed
out to the commune there
and we ended up staying in
the area for about 10 years.
What do you know these memories
and well the only thing i
remember was intolerable falls
when we were living in this kind of.
Well i suppose you could call it a house
it was a wooden platform with a big old
army tent and as sort of like
construction over the top of it
and struggling to get it built in the
wet season and with you know ticks
and rain and all the rest of it
and i just remember having complete
freedom to sort of swim in the creek
and run around there
and you know there are a lot of other
young kids my age sort of just.
Learning to adventure around the
whole place and it was fantastic.
I just remember running around
you know in the sun. Annabelle.
Nothing about your child.
Well you know. I suppose.
I would i would have swapped a little bit
of the the actual security of knowing
that you have a completely. You're home.
Like because we did move around quite
a bit and a lot of the dwellings
that we were living in were pretty
kind of makeshift from time to time
but then again you know there
are a lot of sort of advantages
that come along with that as well
because you know i always felt
that i was part of a larger
community and stuff like that
and i definitely wouldn't
have stopped any of that.
Have you.
You know how did you realize
you know. Well it was.
I suppose i felt like i was part of a larger
community because we were also sort of
involved in the same things like my
family and all of the other families
and people there were all sort
of hand building their houses
and all facing the problems of all you
know of food and community living
and stuff like that together
and so i saw adults interacting in a
different way to what you see them in
mainstream society and that was
reflected in the children as well
that we sort of stayed together
as a larger group a lot more
and sort of did a lot more of our sort
of daily activities together and.
I suppose my experience
of it was jest as feeling
that all of the adults around
me were a part of my family and
that you know even faces
that i only just recognized i knew
i could trust because of the way
that i'd seen them living around me
and the same with all the children
and i found it very easy to meet
and play with a lot of different
children because i knew
that we were all just part of
this sort of big farm together.
So what about education. Well.
Well major case nimbin was interesting
because i spent some time in the alternative
schools there
but then i also spent most of my primary
school years at the straight school as it
was called which was like the nimbin
central school and it was at a time
when children from the
alternative families
and the hippy settlers around the place
were starting to go to the sort of central
school and they were starting to actually
be interaction between the hippy kids
and the straight kids and.
Can imagine it was quite a
kind of intense sort of thing
that was going on within the classrooms
because there's a lot of contention between
them which i suppose i just a reflection
of the tension in the whole community
but that tension between
us sort of dissipated
and we actually got our act together over
the years that i was in primary school
and it was a really interesting thing because
i remember at like you know in years.
One and two and three feeling
very sort of threatened
and intimidated by the straight
kids and very separate from them
and then over the years.
Actually everything became a lot
more relaxed and a lot more positive
and by the end of
that time there was actually a real
lot of positive stuff happening
and it was funny because
i didn't see as much of
that in the adult community as i did.
Among the kids and so you
know it was i suppose
that was a kind of a special thing that was
going on. When i've lived in position.
What was it about. What we
hear is the difference. Well.
All of the straight kids felt as though.
The hippy children in their
school were sort of dirty
and weren't as sort of refined as them
and didn't have a christian upbringing
was a very important part of it and.
Also kind of felt that their
parents and that they as well.
Were an intrusion into the kind
of routine and the pattern
that have been set up in that area
and i suppose in a way that's rightly so
because we were playing in what used to be
their playgrounds and their older brother's
playgrounds and stuff like that but.
I suppose as the years
went by and they realized
that we could be just as much
fun and just as creative
and just as kind of into sport
and into all of those things
that they were into all of
that started to break away
and i member sort of in
my ear in particular.
Every time we all went on an
excursion together or did something
that brought us together all of
that stuff started to break down
and i suppose you know it did break down a
lot faster among us than i did among the
adults. And you know we would have parties
and i remember having parties myself
where straight kids would come over
and they would look different and speak
differently and all that kind of stuff
and they would kind of
tentatively walk into our house
and see all of the sort of hippy ornaments
and stuff like that around the place
and just be absolutely fascinated that
they were allowed to go inside that
when their parents were so hesitant
about having anything to do with
that part of the community
and you know they were actually
quite proud of themselves
that they were able to go
and you know participate with us until
let us into their lives as well.
Because you know it was something that
their parents just weren't able to do
and i mean i go to meetings
now and i'm 19 years old
and i see all of the faces
of those kids parents
and it's still just a wall
of resistance you know
and i remember sort of 10 years ago.
Breaking through that wall with all those
kids and having a great time with them
but now you know it's just there
are some things in that community
that will never change. You know.
You know. Life is.
Whose owners.
I suppose. Among the adults
the thing that i remember is.
Walking up see we lived in a house just
behind a craft gallery in town there for
quite a long time we had
that house for 10 years
and i remember walking up at nighttime
and just seeing the kind of things
that were going on in the streets
there and a lot of them.
I didn't really understand
but i could actually see the
mechanism between the straits
and the hippies outwork
and you know i would see a bunch of really
aggressive kind of you know people run
across from the rainbow cafe and
punch in the windows of the pub
and then run away
and all the strays would come running out
of the pub you know around closing time
and fight with these people in the
street and i saw that happening a lot
and you know it was a kind of two sides
of the street type of thing going on for
quite a while and i just remember.
You know hearing a lot of
complaints about the way
that the straits lived in the town
from from the alternative people
that the noise from the pub and the
alcohol and all that kind of stuff
and you know those kind of criticisms were
just as strong as the criticisms from
straight people about you know smoking
grass in the street and stuff like
that as well. And so i suppose you
know you ask me about criticisms
and straightaway i'm talking about the drug
issue there as you know it seems to be
where everything leads to doesn't.
So. Well yeah absolutely.
Because you know.
When i came around there was a lot of
hypocrisy in in terms of those two sides
of the community criticising each other
because you've got all of you know all of
these straights in town at night
getting really really drunk in the pub
and playing a lot of really loud music
and getting aggressive and violent
and tearing up and down in their
cars and light type of thing
and then their wives
and their families a criticising the
alternative community for smoking drugs in the
street and for that disrupting their
community and yet the community
that they were talking about you know it
had a very sort of destructive face to it
as well and i member. You know
on the straight kids farms.
There was you know a lot of kind
of guns and a lot of violence
and a lot of sort of stories about
domestic violence and stuff like that
and it was all very scary
to me just the same way
that among those straight families you know
the whole idea of kind of smoking dope
in your family and
and sort of you know people hanging around
naked on your community must have been
very scary to them. So what was that.
You know she was you know.
What was i mean i think about your life.
Well the whole thing about relating to other
adults in a similar way to how you do
with your parents and you know sort
of feeling that that feeling of trust
and feeling comfortable around
a whole community of people
and spending a lot of time you
know in sort of families that.
Asians are other people's
places and stuff like that
and also feeling as though not just your
house is the safest place in the world
but like the whole community
is somewhere where you belong
and you know you can kind of wonder
among all those different people
and still feel at home. And i think
that was the main thing because i noticed
you know among the straight kids
that they had a very kind of territorial
thing about their mum and their dad
and their family and i sort of just
really never felt there. And i was.
Of course. Yeah absolutely.
Because i mean you know my parents still
played just as powerful a role in my life
as this is there was also this whole
sort of added security of knowing that
that you know you were a part of this kind
of meaningful thing going on all around
you and all of those people celebrated
together and work together and all
that kind of stuff and you know.
Just that that feeling of assurance was
that was what i felt surrounded
by my whole childhood.
I think you know from. You know. You know.
You know they're looking to that
you know how do you know the rest.
Yeah. I think i learnt a lot about being
open minded to people's points of view
and being acceptant of people's
limitations and stuff like that
and i think i learnt about
sort of listening to people
and being compassionate to people's kind
of predicament or the people situation
and so rather than always having a kind
of you know a motivated sort of point of
view about things where
you've got something to prove
or you've made a decision how you feel about
things to actually sort of let things
flow a bit more and to to see
situations change and come and go
and be a bit more accepting of that
kind of thing and i don't know.
You know how much it's actually rubbed off
say politically or anything like that
but i would say that. You know just
in terms of kind of social situations
and stuff like that. I think a little
bit more easygoing about you know about
that type of thing. It's
hard to actually explain.
You know the way
that those values affect your behaviour
now because you know it's pretty much
invisible to me
and i don't feel i don't feel different to
all of the you know people in mainstream
society that i'm relating to now
but sometimes i feel as though i'm a little
bit ready more ready to be open minded
into graft situations for what they are
than people who have got a whole load of
kind of preconceived ideas
that they've been taught in a very linear
way from their family and their parents.
They were so.
No they weren't the only the only
sort of frightening situations
that i can remember were sort
of up in town late at night
when you know there was sort
of violence going on around me
and i felt really kind of afraid and loan
and i remember sometimes sort
of out at the bush holes
when they'd have big
dances and bands out there
and sometimes those kind
of situations we get ugly
and i would suddenly feel completely
alienated from the whole thing and
that could be very frightening
sometimes and i suppose.
Like living there has also been conducive
to me kind of you know trying different
drugs and stuff like that
which you know i probably.
It's not that i regret doing
assess that i realize now
that there's actually you know
no need to go as far into
that as a lot of people do.
And so i suppose you know i didn't
i didn't need that kind of thing
but then there are a lot of other people
who have those kind of you know who have
other reference points.
You know forced upon them as well like
you know all those people who get into
driving fast cars around
and most people who get into
just hanging out at the beach
and doing nothing else you know assess
the thing that young people do together
and it doesn't in the end it
doesn't matter whether it's one
or the other you know so you know. Don't
think there were any downsides at all.
Were you friends you grew
up with. The russians so.
For you. I suppose.
That makes your original question
a little bit more clear.
For me there were less
downsizing growing up in
that community because we also maintained
a lot of ties with people outside
and i was aware of the
value of a lot of things
that were going on in mainstream
society and i was aware
that i was going to participate.
And
that although i was growing up in this
nice kind of insular supportive community
that i had a role to play in
mainstream society as well and
that you know i needed to
be able to communicate
and i needed to be able to be sort
of welfare scented and confident
and straightforward and
all that type of thing.
And so you know i managed to learn a bit
about open mindedness and letting go
and stuff like that by living there.
But then also keep it together
enough to go back and do something
that i consider to be worthwhile. You
know participating with everyone.
Whereas a lot of people who you know
grew up as hippies out there became very
resentful about a lot of
things in mainstream society
that made them very kind
of afraid to participate
and so they became really kind of afraid
of the way that the government works
and afraid of the way that the system
works and afraid of a lot of things
that people do you know on a large scale
because you know they weren't used to all
those mechanisms and they weren't open
minded to and they've been taught
that all that was really bad and that's
why their parents ran away from it
and so a lot of those people have
really you know fallen by the wayside
and found very little to turn to
other than sort of you know drugs
and kind of you know very kind of how would
you say close knit afraid little groups
that they hide in. And you see a lot
of those people in the streets in them
and you. You know.
You know here was just a.
Yes yes. Well.
It's you know a very important industry.
There are sort of you know a lot of
people pushing heroin and stuff like
that through this area who kind of
you know realize that it's a lot.
It can be a lot more lucrative than working
just in sydney and stuff like that
and they come up here with
intention of making a lot of money
and often supporting her as well
and you know it ties in perfectly
with the with the marijuana industry
that exists here
and you know all the people who do it you
know basically really bad greedy people
and into people and you see it
going on all the time down there
and you know it's fine.
It doesn't bother me at all
because you know the only people
that they're enduring if people
that are gullible enough to go
and pay a lot of money for marijuana and
so crying at themselves and you know.
So it is one.
It's just another one of those
industries just like fast food
or you know cheap cars or whatever.
So you know more people.
No it doesn't yet.
As far as i'm concerned you know the
drug situation in the streets of nimbin
doesn't actually need defending.
Because the people who are
peddling the hard drugs.
You know are just sort of
doing their own evil thing
and you know anyone who chooses to participate.
You know enters at their own risk.
And the people who are kind of falling
for and buying dope to support
that whole sort of system.
You know just kind of you know
following their own indulgent pursuits
and that's fine if they
want to pay money for it
and you know that's their problem
and i suppose the unfortunate thing about
it is kind of gullible people who come to
him and they don't know what they're
looking for and they find grass
and they get smashed and sit in the
main street you know looking dazed
and confused and you just have to realize
that those people have
fallen by the wayside.
And if their choice to be
stationary and indolent
and you know to not
participate in their society
or not to take advantage of what they do.
When do and you know people
choose to do that in lots of ways
and you know sitting around in nimbin
getting smashed is just as repetitive as
working in a steel factory
or you know doing anything else which
is kind of mind numbingly boring.
What about. You talk about.
You your friends your peers who
are now back in their own.
You know i was both a story. I'm sure.
Yeah well you know among people
who have grown up the way
that i have they're living on
communes and stuff like that
but still actually getting an
education and still realizing
that you know there's a whole world of
things to do out there a lot of them like me
you know have sort of been
down in sydney and i.
Going back there and stuff like that
but then there's another group of people
who have sort of stayed out there
and actually made a success
out of living in the way
that their parents have established and.
I think that's a really really positive
thing because you know you can actually
create a really good life for yourself
out there if you choose to do that
and if you feel comfortable staying
in that area and so for example.
It's funny it's mainly people who
are. You know i mean it's that again.
Now you know i guess.
And so among that group of people
who've grown up the way i have
and i've chosen to stay out there and to
and to you know keep living in that area.
A lot of them of kind of become
involved in alternative employment
and self-employment
and a few people come to mind like a musician
i know who you know could be just as
successful playing in bands
in sydney or up here
and chooses to keep living on the come in
that his dad you know
was part of setting up
and is now kind of you know recording
music out there and playing gigs in town
and doing all all that kind of thing
and that really works for him
and i think that's fantastic. And
i also know a girl my age who.
Sort of designs clothes and makes her own
clothes and sells markets around here
and stuff like that and she's just
had a child up at the comment
that i still live on paradise valley
and you know has a really nice kind of
existence up there with her boyfriend in you
know an old house and i know the
people that lived in that house before
and now she's living there with a
bunch of people you know who i knew
when we were all young together and
you know i think it's fantastic
that they've chosen to stay around
and make the best of what their
parents are established there. And.
I suppose you know it would be very hard
to actually to actually say the difference
between those people and the
people who have you know kind of.
How do you say where that
whole thing has collapsed.
It's a bit hard to explain this is
that this generation you know just.
You know i wouldn't say that people
my age choosing to stay in this area
and make a go of it would
be the actual next chapter.
Because a lot more of the people who stay
around end up finding themselves quite
trapped and quite kind of you know
unproductive in that situation
and i suppose there are only a few of them
who've really kind of you know settled
in and wanted to stay there.
I'd say that the next kind of.
Stage in the process of the whole thing
will be a new type of people coming to
that area
and they'll be alternative settlers in
the true sense of the word just like my
parents generation were
but they'll be choosing
that those alternatives for different
kind of reasons and they'll be realizing
that they can still participate in
mainstream society and still have jobs
and still do all of that type of thing
but they don't actually have to live in
the middle of the city in order to do it
and that they can also integrate
that into having a more kind of down to
earth lifestyle and you know you see
that kind of thing happening this area quite
a lot where there are people who have
been educated.
And gone to university and
become sort of either doctors
or you know any kind of professions like
that and then chosen to go and practice
or do their thing you know in an area
where they can also live on the land
and have a really sort of
comfortable life like that
and i suppose you know you
could be kind of critical of
that because you know a lot of people
say all those people belong in the city
and that's where they should stay
but i don't necessarily agree with
that i think if you're a writer or you
know a doctor or you know a schoolteacher
or any of those kind of professions
and you wanted to live on the land
animals a perfect place to go
and do it you know and you can.
You know have a small block of land
like the you know permaculture plots
that are coming up now and stuff like
that you could have a small plot of land
and just get on with it and you know
and live your life the way
you want to in terms of that
and because there's so much.
You know communication sort of technology
becoming available for you to stay
integrated with the rest of society. You
know i think we'll see a lot more of that.
So what do you have a future.
For the area for me.
Well i hope that the process that
that is happening now continues to happen
which is like people realizing what are
the good parts and what are the
bad parts out of the alternative
that they've created
and actually you know starting to to
look at it all in the positive sense of
creating
and maintaining something that's really
going to work not just something
that will help them to survive running away
from everything else you know because a
lot of people really did just run
there for shelter from a society
that was running off the rails you know.
And now they've done that it's time to
start maintaining the good parts of it
and you know just like in the garden
making the good parts of the grow
and getting rid of the stuff that that
you don't need. And what about you.
Do you think it's i mean.
You know. Well we live.
You know in the main part of town for
about 10 years and so i've had plenty of
that now but you know if i you
know ever wanted to settle down
and kind of live in a you
know family situation
or in a community situation i
would definitely choose this area
and whether it was kind of
in the actual nimbin valley
or in the surrounding communities
or you know just in the general area
like you know bangalow way or ever.
You know i know
that i'll always be have ties with this
area because you know the land feels so
good to me here and that i
definitely want to go and you know.
Shake it up a little bit in the city
first and travel around the world
and all those kind of things you
know and and meet the kind of people
that would have never even conceived of
anything like nimbin because there's a
whole world of fascinating people out there
who are doing totally different things
to that you know and it's not as
though there's just sort of sydney
and melbourne and then the alternative to
that is you know living up on a community
is sort of a whole other strata as a
society that you know that i
want to get into as well. So.
That's fine. Years.
You know.
I think i can tell a story that makes.
All of the positive things that is had about
as communities look really bad. I can.
Well most of the people when i
was really young about four
or five years old all the people living out
on tumble were sort of you know pretty
form kind of hippies
and you know we're all pretty much in the
same situation of you know building our
own houses and growing a lot of grass and
selling and stuff like you know one year.
I'm sure you'll hear a few stories about
this is a big bust out of town a ball
and a lot of people got bailed up for
and i was a protest about the way
that it was all done but these people
ended up doing some time. Anyway.
And i remember we were
living in the garden house
and that's right down in the bottom
of the valley where the road comes up
and ends and. That's where everyone
sort of goes into trouble from there.
So you know one night we had this
kind of sound from way up on the hill
and it was a truckload of all of these
people who had been in prison for a couple
of weeks or whatever they were
coming back onto the commune
and they were really really drunk
and they weren't the kind of people
that drank a lot because as i said
they were used to just growing
and smoking grass instead.
And they were old is
absolutely out of their heads
and they came tearing back through
the valley and parked the truck
and came stumbling through
the whole area screaming
and banging on doors
making a hollywood noise
and the whole place was just you know
terrified of what they were doing
and i don't know how it ended up because
last thing i mean it was hiding under my
pillow at the noise of these drunken
hippies stumbling through their community.
You know in victory that they'd been let
out and i'm going to the next morning
and wondered out into the yard
and the whole yard was going to
live with these white patches
that they'd left sort of stumbling
through hurling all over our lawn
and i mean i was appalled because i was
used to them being such kind of peaceful
people but to see them on the rampage like
that as kind of a whole you know all of
these hippies must have a bit of you know
straight in them.
As well as traits having a
bit of you in them as well.
Because you.
Was there was no they didn't have wild
names at all. Actually your generous.
No no no they didn't. All the hippy kids
and you had you know. Names like ours.
And.
And i suppose there were some
pretty wild adventures at school
but not really the kind
of things i can describe.
I think in primary school.
All of the hippie kids kind of picked up
on on the straight routine quite fast
because you know we had the school
socials and we had kind of you know
that youth group and stuff like
that and hippie kids and say kids.
All treated that is actually the same way
and we you know we all knew how
much fun it was to get dressed up
and get into music and you
know door that type of thing.
And so there was you know it was no big
deal there at all if you give me a minute
i'll be able to think of funny
stories when. I also remember.
A lot of kind of parties and things
like that the my parents took me to
when i was young and
especially around the times
and i you three first of all it
was a 10 years after festival.
Remember seeing kind of their
insane type of parties
that they used to set up in the halls out
there like there was the blue knob hall
which was famous for big sort of end
of year parties and things like that
and they had a lot of mask parties
and a lot of that type of thing
and at each one of these parties
there were certain things
that were guaranteed you'd always have a
whole load of people with really long
dreadlocks kind of standing around playing
percussion you know in the main hall
and a lot of people jumping around to
that and a lot of kids running around
and then behind
that there was always some kind of kitchen
where someone would have set up a height
of really bizarre food. I mean foods
are pretty loose term but then you
and they'd be really stone people
eating just eating this stuff insanely
and behind that if you
when you go out the back door of these holes
you generally just like a big patch of
grass out there and it always be a bonfire
and these people with really kind of nerdy
dreadlocks sitting really in close to
the fire and just sort of staring into
the phone tripping off their heads
and it would just go on and on and
on and people just kind of circulate
and you go out and sit by the fire
fry and get warm and then you go in
and eat some of this food and you
go and listen to music for a while
and you just keep going you know all night
and these to make these amazing kind of
brews of with magic mushrooms like a china
tea with magic mushrooms in it
and some people would just be you know
drinking the stuff by by the liter and.
I mean i thought some pretty
incredible things i suppose
and they don't really seem
that bizarre to me because i've seen
those people doing that for years
and it seems like a natural way
to celebrate to me but it.
If you went there for the first time you
really be amazed at the castle fees to do
remember the 1983 festival
seeing a similar kind of thing.
I mean they're all of the normal
type of pursuits like you know.
Is a train going to ruin years so they're
all the sort of normal festival things to
do like you know the music and the
sweat lodge and all that type of thing
and running around in the fields
and then i remember seeing a group of
trippers a festival who were all sitting
around in this massive kind of circle
holding hands and staring up at the sky
and sort of chanting these
really is really weird chance
and i mean we're watching it
and actually trying to sort out what they
were doing and i really just gave up
and walked away because i
couldn't i couldn't understand.
You know what they're actually
going for it all the hoes.
I suppose the funny things that i
used to see where the kind of things
that people would get up to
when they were stone in the actual streets
as a child i didn't have any problem
with kind of watching quite closely the
type of things that they were doing
and not actually being offended by it
but just sort of checking them out.
I remember.
You know the kind of really derelict hippies
who who you know don't change their
clothes for weeks and stuff like that
and they would get really really drunk
or smash in the street and
it's kind of sit there either.
Either begging or or trying to
irritate people as they walk past
and i swear to watch of ours
and just sort of you know try
and work out where they were coming from
and i remember this one guy
who's a famous character.